>> Tucker: IF YOU SAW THE SHOW
LAST NIGHT YOU SAW THAT
DR. MARC SIEGEL ASKED THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT THE COGNITIVE
ABILITY TEST WHITE HOUSE
PHYSICIANS HAVE GIVEN HIM.
AMAZINGLY THE PRESIDENT WAS
HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT DETAILS.
USE PART OF IT.
>> President Trump: THERE WERE
30-35 QUESTIONS AND THE FIRST
QUESTIONS ARE VERY EASY IN THE
LAST QUESTIONS ARE MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT.
LIKE A MEMORY QUESTION.
LIKE YOU WILL GO PERSON, WOMAN,
MAN, CAMERA, TV.
SO THEY SAY, COULD YOU REPEAT
THAT?
SO I SAID YEAH.
SO IT’S A PERSON, WOMAN, MAN,
CAMERA, TV.
OKAY, THAT’S VERY GOOD.
>> Tucker: SO GUESS WHO ELSE
WAS WATCHING THAT?
THE WEIGHT LIFTER, OVER ON CNN,
AND HIS BUDDY, DON LAMON.
SO THE WEIGHT LIFTER, THE
GOVERNOR’S BROTHER DECIDED TO
ADMINISTER THE TEST THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN TO
INTERNATIONAL TV STARVED ON THEM
ON.
AND WHAT HAPPENS NEXT?
>> WENDY TO TAKE THAT, THAT
LOOKS LIKE SOMETHING FOR MIDDLE
SCHOOL.
>> WELL YOU TAKE THAT WHEN THE,
I’M NOT A DOCTOR AND I WILL LET
DR. REINER EXPLAIN IT, BUT
USUALLY WHEN THERE IS SOME ISSUE
OR CONCERN ABOUT, YOU KNOW, YOUR
COGNITIVE ABILITIES.
>> WHAT WERE THE ANIMAL SHAPES?
>> IT’S A LION, A HIPPO AND A
CAMEL.
>> ARE RIGHT NOW.
>> YOU GUYS DON’T EVEN KNOW.
[LAUGHS]
>> I’M LOOKING AT IT BACKWARDS.
>> Tucker: WHAT DOES IT MEAN
IF YOU DON’T KNOW A RINO FROM AN
ELEPHANT?
WELL YOU MAY NOT BE A PHYSICIAN
BUT I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT IT
MEANS.
IT MEANS A LOW ACUITY AND THAT’S
NOT A SURPRISE IN IN THE CASE OF
DON LAMON.
A PERFECTLY CHEERFUL PERSON BUT
MAY BE THE SLOWEST PERSON EVER
TO APPEAR ON CABLE NEWS.
YOU MAY HAVE FORGOTTEN, AND IF
YOU HAVE FORGOTTEN WE HAVE THE
TAPE, HIS MALAYSIA AIRLINES
SEGMENT WHERE HE SUSPECTED ME
WITH THE FLIGHT HAD VANISHED
INTO A BLACK HOLE.
>> WHETHER IT WAS TERRORISM OR
MECHANICAL FAILURE, IT’S
SOMETHING WE DON’T UNDERSTAND, A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ASKING
ABOUT BLACK HOLES AND ON AND ON
AND THEY ARE ALSO REFERENCING
THE TWILIGHT ZONE WHICH IS A
VERY SIMILAR PLOT.
THAT’S WHAT PEOPLE ARE SAYING,
AND I KNOW IT’S PREPOSTEROUS,
BUT IS IT PREPOSTEROUS, DO YOU
THINK, MARY?
>> Tucker: IT TURNS OUT
BECAUSE WE HAVE ACCESS TO A
SCIENTIFIC POLL PORTAL THAT WE
CALLED GOOGLE THAT THE NUMEROUS
BLACK HOLE IS ABOUT 3,000
LIGHT-YEARS AWAY AND BOEING
TRIPLE SEVENS CAN’T YET FLY THAT
FAR.
IT MAY SEEM THAT WE ARE BEING A
LITTLE BIT CRUEL, BUT LET ME SAY
THAT THERE IS LOVE AT THE BOTTOM
OF THIS.
PULL IT UP AGAIN ON GOOGLE.
IN WHICH HE DECLARED WITH TOTAL
ASSUREDNESS THAT THE FROZEN
DESERT BUT THE REST OF US CALL
SORBET, IT’S ACTUALLY PRONOUNCED
SORE BET.
HE WAS ADAMANT ABOUT THAT.
HOW A CAR IS THE UNDISPUTED
KING OF ENGLAND, AND HE’S LIVE
TONIGHT.
>> HAVING WATCHED DON THE MONT
ON NEW YEAR’S EVE, I THINK IF HE
HAD BEEN PRESENTED WITH
SILHOUETTES OF A DIFFERENT TYPE
OF PRODUCT, I THINK HE WOULD
HAVE DONE FINE.
YOU KNOW, SHOT GLASS, COCKTAIL
GLASS, I ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT
LAWYERS LEARNED EARLY ON THAT
YOU NEVER ASK QUESTIONS IN COURT
OF A WITNESS UNLESS YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THEM.
OBVIOUSLY THEY DIDN’T DO TOO
MUCH PREP FOR THE INTERVIEW.
THEY JUST FIGURE IF TRUMP SAYS
HE DIDN’T TAKE THE TEST, THEN
THEY HIT HIM AND THEY SAY WHY
WANT TO TAKE THE TEST?
SO HE TAKES THE TEST AND THEY
MAKE A SUPPORT OF HIM ANYWAY.
YOU KNOW I’VE TAKEN THIS TEST
AND I THOUGHT THE PRESIDENT
SUMMED IT UP PRETTY WELL.
YOU KNOW IMMEDIATELY WHETHER YOU
ARE ACING IT OR NOT, THE FACE OF
A CLOCK WITH NO ARMS ON IT, THEY
SAY WHAT IT IS-10?
THOSE ARE THE SAME KIND OF TEST
THAT THEY GIVE YOU AN FIELD
SOBRIETY TESTS.
>> Tucker: THAT SOMETHING HE
WOULD PASS.
THERE’S SOMETHING ENDEARING
ABOUT THE FACT, BUT DON LAMON, A
THING EMBARRASSES HIM.
IS THERE SOMETHING KIND OF
APPEALING ABOUT THAT?
>> WOULDN’T YOU LOVE THAT?
AND RECITE THE ALPHABET
BACKWARDS, SENATOR .
THEY NEVER GET MUCH BEYOND M OR
N.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE JOE BIDEN
TAKE DAYS?
HE INVENTED TWO NEW JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS IN THE LAST 48
HOURS.
DO YOU EVER HEAR OF VOTER
REGISTRATION AND A PAID
CAREGIVER?
AND THE DISEASE PUT EVERYBODY IN
LOCKDOWN, IT’S NOT COVID-19,